للفوز بانتخابات 2024 جو بايدن يبحث عن
وسائل جديده للوصول الى الناخبين والحل
الامثل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
البيت الابيض سيعتمد على مئات المؤثرين
على المنصات الاجتماعيه للترويج لسجله
وسيتم توفير غرفه احاطه خاصه بهم
الخطوه تهدف الى تعزيز مكانه بايدن بين
الناخبين خاصه الشباب والتوجه نحو الذين
قد لا يتابعون البيت الابيض او الحزب
الديمقراطي على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
خطوه البيت الابيض علامه على ان غرفه
الاحاطه الصحفيه التقليديه لم تعد مركز
الرسائل الوحيد للاداره الامريكيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات